[Music]
as prominent members of the
asian-american community we were asked
to talk about what Andrew yang has said
during the quarantine times you guys
know what I'm talking about
nope no oh you don't know at all no hey
so this time as my pants were around my
ankles and I was doing what quarantine
OHS do which is what jacking off I said
to myself this is something we need to
spring up into action and address
especially because of a lot of our fan
base was saying you guys need to say
something about this so because we
couldn't get together and do no JK news
while my pass was around my ankles yeah
I said to myself I'm gonna do my
patriotic duty to [ __ ] respond to
this [ __ ] and give my piece and I saw
you you went at it too I don't remember
I said water you well you you you we all
we both commented yeah yeah yeah and um
I think we reached out specifically I'm
sorry I do most of your great ideas come
when your pants are down in many ways
yeah did you finish I had to stop it was
that it was that important edge for this
I urged did you do with your free hand
or did you did you double hand this task
I had a double hand I completely take my
hand off my dick that means it was a big
I was scrolling on Instagram and feeling
myself and I came across this and I saw
many people said you need to say
something Joe okay so here's what it is
so a lot of people in the Asian American
community celebrities public figures
they were all outraged at what Andrew
yang has said even fellow youtubers even
comedians a lot of people people we know
man so Andrew yang did this Washington
Post op-ed right and in that he said a
few things that rub people the wrong way
when I was rubbing myself the right way
I like that one so if you this is these
are the last two paragraphs that I think
angered the most people
but it starts off with him talking about
how he was shopping and so he's like
kind of relating because I think
somewhat like a teenage boy y'all [ __ ]
out of the window so like through this
whole corona theme Asians have been
experiencing a lot more racism so this
is what his opinion piece is about and
then this is towards the end of his
actual thing on the Washington Post
which you can look up during World War
two Japanese Americans volunteered for
military duty at the highest possible
levels to demonstrate that they were
Americans now many in the asian-american
community are stepping up trying to
demonstrate that we can be part of the
solution some 17 percent of US doctors
are Asian and rushing to the front lines
we Asian Americans need to embrace and
show our Americanist in ways we never
have before we need to step up help our
neighbors donate gear vote wear red
white and blue volunteer fund aid
organizations and do everything in our
power to accelerate the end of this
crisis we should show without a shadow
of a doubt that we are Americans we'll
do our part for our country in this time
of need demonstrate that we are part of
the solution we are not the virus but
can be part of the cure that sounds
great it does but also at the yeah but
also man why do we gotta prove ourselves
that's the main point feel the same way
show that we are American even though we
are you know mean like my people don't
have to come out and say guess what guys
were Americans so we're gonna show it to
you you know what I mean now he glossed
by the beating part like really fast too
but then the big thing that he brought
up was that he brought Japanese
Americans signed up to be in the
military to show that they were American
but it's not like they did it in a
positive way where it was like yeah [ __ ]
yeah America was because he felt like
they had to in that well I'll tell you a
little insider secret about the Japanese
Americans because we have well I have
personal family that told me what went
down that's not written in the history
books right so when I was arguing in the
comments during this time with my pants
back up up now cuz I was serious right
at this point
I was like I gotta say something about
this because what maybe Andrew doesn't
know cuz he learned this in school right
what maybe he doesn't know that what
really went down is Somyot
basically what happened was the
japanese-american population had to
whitewash themselves in order to have
longevity in this country they all got
together and they said what's happening
like how come you know we have some
World War one vets we have people that
dedicated their lives to this country
why did they round us up and put us into
the cats
maybe they saw us as a foreign threat
because we're not speaking English
enough maybe because we're not going
into these communities and being a part
of the community we're sticking to
ourselves too much right so a lot of
them actually destroyed their own
culture out of survival and so that's
not something like hey let me be more
American that's more like I don't want
people to round me up and take all my
possessions so maybe what we have to do
is send our children to work as you know
doctors and and military guys and
politicians so they're so engrained into
the society that there's no way they can
do that to our people anymore
and so if you notice there's a lot of
japanese-americans that don't even know
how to speak Japanese and but Chinese
Americans that have been here for
generations they still continue the
culture and then they might learn and
will pass it down and they can celebrate
a lot of Chinese culture but a lot of
Japanese Americans are whitewashed and
they forgot a lot about that stuff
because they purposely didn't teach them
the Japanese and all that stuff so they
basically genocided their own culture in
order for long-term survival so it's not
something that was done out of like
let's embrace America it was done out of
out of survival of like I got to throw
away this and I got to wear a red white
and blue and have [ __ ] American
birthday cakes and flags all over the
place in order to be accepted so it's
not such a good look I know that Andrew
was probably using that example as like
hey in a crisis if they see it as a
foreign threat we got to get ahead of
that by showing even more that I am on
your side right but I think it's a
different time now because because of
what Asian Americans did back in the day
I think that is what makes us today we
can say whatever the [ __ ] we want
without rocks being thrown at us or
whatever we can tell them straight up
like no I'm an American too and I don't
have to pretend and [ __ ] brown-nose
and I don't have to prove myself because
I have just as many of the same whites
you do but back then they had to do that
yeah the part is the part of me I guess
that felt sad when I first read it it
wasn't it's it's kind of aside from the
actual op-ed it was just I don't even
read the op-ed first when I first saw
was pretty much seen like the entire
asian-american community turned their
backs on someone they backed as a
presidential candidate overnight do you
feel like they've turned their backs
completely or they are still pointing
out the flaws in someone well I don't
know so it's hard to say it's hard to
know right because everyone's tweeting
instagramming so it's like a sentence
here a comment there but the way that
they're saying it's like if you if
someone's beloved to me right if they
say something I've seen people even when
Kanye was saying like slavery's in the
mine or he says some crazy [ __ ] there's
people that are coming out like let's
say a big boy from Powell on a six at
the time he goes let me help explain
while he's talking about our other
people come let me help explain so
there's no benefit of the doubt
right so yeah it's just people just
straight up just comment oh my god this
is ridiculous and they're just
straight-up just roasting his ass
without offering a solution without even
trying to it didn't seem like any of our
fellow Asian people we're trying to see
what he was trying to get at and so for
me I think you could have worded it way
better but because I am asian-american
and I've been in the military I kind of
understand the merits of what he's
talking about so like he's also and you
also have to keep in mind his background
right here's the entrepreneur so
entrepreneurs coming from startups
they're very solution-based very
pragmatic so for him he's like okay cool
this worked in the past this what we
need to do so he's taking emotions out
of it yeah these stories out of its
cultural context things out of the he's
just seeing flattened the curve here
flattened the curve here what's another
thing you know just like president LOH
has presidents what's gonna be good
solution so that's me understanding his
entrepreneurial mind
so he's instead of like coming forth and
like hyping all the Asians up and giving
a great Obama style speech that really
has no substance he doesn't want to just
rob people but make people feel good
he's like these are some actions that
you can do you can do and it's too cold
because what people wanted at this time
they just want to feel good first well
they wanted they wanted him to condemn
the racism yeah not to say we have to be
the bigger person because I'm pragmatic
too so I speak his language I see the
goal I'm just like yeah
imagine how bad the races will look with
all of us
asian-americans are donating and doing
more than these guys in their supposed
own country right so we're doing more
we're volunteering more we're giving all
these things to help better the cause
and so the racist guys are looking worse
so it's a it's more like a strategic
thing of better PR for the people or
whatever but I think what people are
saying here and doing here is they're
more like oh man it feels like you
didn't really back us up and you just
told us to kind of suck it up and but in
my I agree with you man I think what
what's happening but he did my he might
have jumped the gun at that point maybe
he was supposed to agree with everyone
hide people get people to feel good and
their offer solutions but I think
because he's just so quick to jump to
like this what we need to do yeah people
didn't follow him along his thoughts but
yeah the problem I guess is that I get
what he's doing he's like let's turn
this negative into a positive
yeah right but the problem with that is
that like we have to dig to find that
message right so it's the same thing
with Kanye or same thing with Trump it's
like the main argument for them all the
time is it's not what he's saying it's
what he meant but then what he's saying
you know what I mean cuz I think also in
the article before that part he was
bringing up the Japanese soldiers and
how they were awarded all these medals
right that that the troop that was like
saving live the 442nd
no I was the other part of the history
where it was a segregated you know group
and then they also lost way more lives
and they saved because they were saying
it's a most dangerous situation false
big are [ __ ] around that it's still
surrounded by so much racism but to only
point pinpoint that like positive thing
that they got medals ignores a lot of
racism and that's what a lot of people
are you know have a problem the part
that I'm actually I have a problem with
isn't even if this it's just like our
community like if we ever do want to
make a voice the last thing we need to
do is have ten other chiefs pop up that
are all giving problems and no one is
going ok this guy is the chief for the
moment let's help that's everyone help
find the benefit of the doubt for this
person so we can at least stick together
I think the the the response was harsh
and you weren't giving the benefit of
the doubt for someone that you backed up
so hard yeah any one of you guys are
someone that I supported if they said
something right the first thing that's
coming to mind is I'm gonna say did you
really mean it that way I would ask him
I would tweet at him and say hey Andrew
yang were you really ashamed about being
Asian and and can you like elaborate on
that cuz I'm taking it may be the wrong
way but what happened was people
immediately felt as though he was
completely telling us to whitewash yeah
he was turning his back on the Asian
community and I thought it was a bit
extreme to to respond that way like for
example C mu he copied and pasted a part
of it and he says hey that's that's a
note for me dawg at a time where Asian
dysphoria from around the world are
experiencing massive racism and
discrimination basically just told it to
suck it up eat a cheeseburger and buy an
American flag our community
unequivocally rejects this piece so to
me of course I see it a seamos hurt
right but also like his response was so
it was in a way world's like pretty much
you're not trying to understand what
Andrews saying but you're just
completely writing it on doctors he's
not going hey guys when he's talking
about red white and blue it means it
like a metaphor you know it's like
there's straight-up comedians just
latching on to certain words like oh my
god Rumi to buy a red one
sure and then like in a time like this
so they're like taking things and then
they're just like I'm like man it's kind
of like it sucks to see my own community
eat each other up and I'm like man that
just yeah that was the part that I was
like yeah because I'm a very macro kind
of guy I suck with micro things like I'm
not a very detail-oriented person so
hearing it in a very macro angle all I
heard was hey the whole world's hurting
we got to come together if we're gonna
beat this virus thing and like just you
know come out on the other end as happy
society we gotta like put aside our
differences and we gotta just knuckle
down and do the work that we're all
supposed to do regardless of race or
whatever you know then the fact that you
threw in the the Asian stuff in there is
like hey this is for us though you know
and I don't know I for me it's like I
hear there's there's two ways to look at
it there's the Malcolm X and there's the
Martin Luther King you know way of going
about things you know and I know his way
was very Martin Luther King turning the
other cheek and lets you know like you
can't fight fire with fire man you got
to put it out and you gotta you know
it's love all around hugs yeah and
there's um like in a one of the other
arguments that I read was you know what
he's been here we've already have to
fight this stuff and how come it's
happening like we shouldn't have to
re-earn our American ship right which I
completely understand agree but for me
I'm like but there's also that's
philosophical that's theoretical and but
there's also reality so reality is black
people have been fighting this [ __ ] way
longer that's exactly the order like in
the military right we when we all go up
to do swim qual like some qualification
when the black person steps in front of
the pool everyone looks if you could
swim and this is like a stereotype that
has been broken a million times but
racism is real or prejudice is real
whether it's it's good or bad or
whatever it's just real right and it's
all how do you how do you battle that
effectively rather than just saying I
wish you never just existed yes what's
the battle effectively this [ __ ]
is probably my sweat his [ __ ] ass off
like David Goggin and turn into a Navy
SEAL
yeah to show everyone I'm [ __ ]
drowned proof [ __ ] and other
people are like why don't we why do I
have to swim and work that hard to prove
that other people you know and then it's
like I think there's it just goes both
ways man but so recently Andrew yang
came back on next shark and he was able
to kind of comment on what he said
earlier right so there is a part that I
felt was kind of weird which is the
whole it made me ashamed to be Asian for
the first time or that feeling right
even though it was very vulnerable to
say it I think that as a leader even
saying that you were ashamed hurts a lot
of p.a does because people were upset by
my use of the word a shame and I think a
better word could have been powerless or
marginalized and so he had some time to
think about it and so he says maybe he
didn't use the right words man I think
he has a lot of awesome ideas and when
you when he gets hit etat I guess I
guess when he has time to reflect and
clarify what he really meant I never
once thought he was telling us you got
to be more white yeah
my first reaction definitely was like I
get what he's saying yeah then my second
reaction was just you but you didn't do
it right but I get it but you didn't do
it right yeah I think the feeling that
he was trying to tell me to be like more
white in that sense no it was just more
of like oh yeah I definitely see the
bigger picture and I don't know for me
I'm I feel like I'm a pretty easygoing
person and like I feel like I don't
really have that many strong opinions so
whatever I would say just like take it
as it is because it's like to me it's
like yeah I wasn't really offended by it
but I understood what he was going at
but I also understand the other side
where it's like we just want to know
that like you're pretty much on our side
and that like why yeah why do we have to
continue fighting exactly that that well
we've already been here we've
established ourselves and for him what
he was coming out and saying is that his
brand of Americanists may not be the
same as yours right or mine or whatever
but he says that's the point of America
right so he's calling for Asians to lean
into their patriotism
and make it your own so it's very
different from saying let's all conform
and so when people took it as like let's
whitewash she was kind of shocked about
that because a lot of people did take it
that way right and that's why when I
when I read that Tim say like wear red
white and blue I pictured it as you do
it in Europe you wear red and blue in
your own way yeah yeah blue is not a
white collar's
he mentioned Japanese Americans and with
the way they did it so the Proms that he
said immediately before that so when you
bring that up again it's like okay
that's not the reason why Japanese
Americans did it you know so if you're
referring to that that's not it but if
you're referring it to the context of
like yeah let's it be American let's you
know pull ourselves up by our bootstraps
then that's great
right so it's yeah it is it is weird
because it wasn't like Japanese
Americans were sitting there like we
gotta be more American let's [ __ ] die
in the war you know they were doing it
out of like survival yeah it goes back
to the whole benefit of the doubt being
wear on my hair everyone be more like
Nadeem here
he lost 50 pounds and then people are
going but did you know if it's cuz
Nadine was suicidal that's why he lost
50 pounds so like they did know that
they have to dig into this extra
negative context instead of trying to
understand where he possibly could be
going could be bad though if he was
suicidal when I first heard his
statement I was just thinking like us a
very um like asian asian solution
because it's like it's like you kind of
take the passive road to just like show
up people you know like you don't know
it's too Zen right it's not
confrontational yeah but it's like
passive enough where it's like okay I'm
still gonna get my point across because
like even though I may be the victim I'm
gonna show you that like I'm not going
to be the victim and that's what I love
about our culture but I think what's
happening right now is a lot of people
in our community are sick and tired of
let's take the higher ground and they
want our leaders to say [ __ ] y'all stop
that [ __ ] so that's what I think is the
sentiment around this is that a lot of
people are like why can't we just be
more outspoken and confrontational and I
don't really agree
and my I think it's all about being
effective so you can say don't do this
and that but I'm more around the Andrew
yang camp you know and then because to
me it's like I don't stoop down to the
level of stupidity and argue with them
or have to tell them cuz stupid is gonna
be stupid I'm gonna waste my time doing
that I'll rather use my time and skills
to do something that's super effective
but mainly I get it though like as
someone who is a leader his words
weigh a lot that's another thing though
words ways the leadership like it
matters because his words are just so
you gotta be carefully you gotta be
careful with that whereas us we even see
the [ __ ] to where we [ __ ] up and we
bullet point some words and yeah if you
just said to help people that's one
thing but I think it's also like he's
like hey let's prove to them that were
good people and people are like what do
I have to prove that's the [ __ ] up
part is we shouldn't and we should never
have we don't have to yeah yeah anything
well yeah that's a good talk guys and
yeah thanks for everyone that's been
bugging us to whoever interrupt me in
the middle of my jerk session thank you
very much
[Music]
[Music]